you know one of the things i was
thinking about yesterday as we saw the
second
impeachment of donald trump is that
for a guy who has been focused on
being a winner winning winning winning
and wanting to be the alpha
and wanting to be the big dog and
wanting to be respected in all of this
stuff
there's really been no bigger loser than
donald trump from the standpoint of
american presidents and what he's done
to his party
and what he's done to the country donald
trump as we mentioned earlier has now
been impeached
twice no president has ever been
impeached twice
donald trump lost the popular vote twice
something no president has done
in more than 100 years it has happened
before but it's been more than a hundred
years
donald trump's presidency oversaw the
loss of the house of representatives for
republicans in 2018
lost the house trump's mishandling of
the virus
has been not only historically
disastrous but
it combined with his wackiness led
republicans to lose
the senate in 2020 and it led to trump
losing the presidential race
and making himself a one-term president
trump has been widely banned
from social media for completely
flouting the rules of those
social media platforms and in so doing
all of this donald trump has also
damaged
his own businesses possibly irreparably
losing contracts with the city of new
york
many of his businesses decimated as
we've discussed and will lead to
investigations of trump's businesses for
possible financial wrongdoing
he has destroyed the reputations of his
children
his son-in-law and so many of the people
around him
possibly irreparably and all of that
talk that trump always says you know no
one's ever seen anything like this
like nobody's ever seen before we've
gotten used to that phrase
he's right it's true trump is right
about that but unfortunately
the superlatives and unprecedented
elements of this presidency
are all bad and unfortunately
a lot of the awakening that we're seeing
didn't happen sooner a lot of the damage
was done
by the time this partial awakening
happened but i think it's also important
for us to understand
that most trumpists have not abandoned
trump there's some good new polling data
that came out i believe it was yesterday
maybe this morning i saw it this morning
which shows that although 10 republican
members of the house did vote to impeach
donald trump
although some senators are saying trump
should go
pat toomey for example we've heard
critical comments from mitt romney
and some republican voters have
abandoned trump by and large
trump continues to be supported by the
republican electorate
and he continues to be seen as
arguably the most dominant and important
force in the republican party so the
idea that on
on wednesday at noon trump becomes
irrelevant to american politics or to
the republican party
so far it doesn't appear to be that way
yes members of the house and senate of
the republican party will as i have told
you
start to distance they will go back to
saying we've got to focus on debt and
deficit and religious freedom and
lowering taxes and cutting regulations
and all of this stuff
and they'll sort of pretend trump never
happened or certainly that they weren't
bigly supportive
of it uh but for now the majority of the
republican
electorate is sticking with him and it's
unclear whether there are going to be
consequences and accountability for
everything donald trump has done
incredibly we know that trump still
thinks he did a great job
he has weaponized his narcissism and
that's exactly why he still thinks he
did a great job
he thinks none of this stuff is his
fault he believes
he's the best when trump says i'm the
best president i've done more than
anybody else
he clearly believes it and it shouldn't
be ignored that despite all of the
losing
trump has gotten things done permanently
and all of them are bad
the judges the court appointments the
um uh that's irreversible they
trump will leave they will stay
continuing to damage the country and
much of that is thanks to mitch
mcconnell
and many of the very republicans that
are now distancing they put in
trump's just uh judges and justices
and uh the time lost with climate
and the environment there's no way to
get that back that's irreversible we can
now try to do even more to make up for
it but every lost day
we never get back but trump's greatest
act
or maybe better said his strongest
action to make
america great or greater is only six
days away which is going to be donald
trump
leaving office arguably as the biggest
loser
to ever be the president of the united
states we'll have more on this
on our instagram page at david pakman
show
and you can also find me on instagram at
david.pacman
one of our sponsors is hydrant which is
a delicious fruit
drink powder that you mix into water for
rehydration and they're giving you 25
off your first order it's made with four
key electrolytes that the body needs
powerfully supporting your hydration
hydrant tastes great
it's made with real fruit juice it's
been a great part of my daily routine
for a while now
keeping myself hydrated puts me in a
better mood
the body needs hydration for basic
energy and focus and hydrant is the
perfect way to rehydrate
especially because it's cost effective
and lower in sugar compared to all of
those popular
sports drinks that are out there you
really have to try it for yourself to
see what i mean
it tastes great they also have a variety
called hydrant
immunity packed with vitamins a b c and
d
which is also very much worth trying
hydrant has a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
off your first order when you go to
drink hydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video